J'ai eu une interview avec Roland Paula
Hood à Manhattan, nous parlons toujours
d'aller à Manhattan pour une
soirée spéciale, ça va être absolument fantastique
s'il ne se classe pas ici de loin le
réalisateur américain le plus intéressant,
aimeriez-vous un scoop que
je peux '  je ne prépare pas le déjeuner s'il
traverse cette crise artistique vidéo c'est
un scoop c'est juste sorti d'ici en essayant de
créer un classique du film noir moderne d'
accord tu veux être dedans hé
hé tu vas garder la bouche fermée
j'ai une petite amie  Shannon je ne
pense pas que je pourrais faire ça 19 prends deux actions
Je dois le trouver avant qu'il n'ait une de ses crises folles, il a dit que ton petit ami ouais petit excentrique Je suis un joueur Je ne sais pas
comment le dire il y a quelque chose de
romantique chez les joueurs peut-être dans les films
mais c'est la vraie vie elle est apparemment
est allé  à une très grande histoire elle prend son
travail très au sérieux ou bonjour je vais
t'aider oh mon dieu tu es Francisco Vega
est-ce bon ou mauvais
hey Ashley je ne peux pas te parler maintenant de
ce qui pourrait être si
secret  qu'à moins qu'il n'y ait des affaires amusantes en
cours à moins qu'il n'y ait
des affaires amusantes en
cours  tout le week-end
je ne devrais pas boire si copieusement je deviens
passionné agressif absurde je viens
[Musique]
toi